- What do we got?
Hey.
I have a military
payment certificate.
It's a $20 one.
And they were paid
to military personnel
to keep the American dollar
out of enemy's hands.
They were produced
around 1940 to 1972.
So how was Vietnam?
[laughter]
WOMAN: I came down in
the shop today to sell
a military payment certificate.
It was paid to military
personnel overseas.
My son purchased it
at a coin auction.
I'm hoping to get $250 out of
it for my son to go to a Boy
Scout trip this summer.
Military payment
certificate for use only
in the United States
military establishments, $20.
They're pretty cool.
When the US was
fighting overseas,
there was a problem
with US soldiers
trading American dollars
on the black market.
So to stop US
dollars from getting
in the hands of enemies,
our government actually
came up with temp currency.
This isn't money.
This is a coupon that's
redeemable for currency.
If you're in the army,
you're in Vietnam,
and they hand you this
instead of real money.
OK.
It was an extreme
morale killer.
Most of these guys are
over there in Vietnam,
they didn't want to be there.
They got drafted into
going, they're making just
a very small amount of money.
And when they go
to get paid they
get handed some fake coupon
thing that says it's money
but it's not.
OK
How much are you
looking to get?
Uh, 250.
250.
OK.
I've seen these go as
high as $2,500, $3,000.
And I'm sure they've
gone for more.
And I've seen them sell for $4.
It's all about condition.
And all this staining
that you see right here,
it really just knocks
the value down.
I'd go like $100.
Can you do $150?
I'll $125.
That's the I'm
going to pay for it.
OK.
Deal.
Deal?
All right.
Meet me over there.
I'll write you up.
OK.
I feel pretty good.
I think my son will enjoy going
to Boy Scout camp this summer.